much needed clean drinking water is now
flowing into tonga navy ship the
aotearoa carried 250 000 liters of water
from new zealand along with a
desalination plant to make more it's a
life-saving delivery after ash from the
volcano blanketed the islands of tonga a
week ago and contaminated the water
supply in auckland there was another
show of pacific island generosity as a
delegation from samoa handed over
supplies to the speaker of tonga's
parliament who says his people are doing
the best they can but still need help i
think people trying to get back to work
restore some sense of normality but at
the same time their disruptions to
services water services power
communication still intermittent at a
government level there's been a rush to
help tonga which analysts believe has
been motivated by humanitarianism
and geopolitical strategic goals
for years western regional powers new
zealand and australia have been worried
about china's growing influence among
the smaller pacific island nations
including tonga there's clearly been
plenty of generosity on display here as
there has been a government level but
after any natural disaster attention
inevitably turns towards the recovery
and rebuilding phase how will that
happen and most importantly who'll pay
tonga thanked china for being the first
to donate money and supplies but before
the eruption tonga's economy was a mess
with the government struggling to pay
back more than a hundred million dollars
that was lent by china after damaging
riots in 2006. beijing has refused to
write the debt off and some believe last
week's natural disaster may provide new
zealand with an opportunity i would say
that in wellington particularly
the pressure coming in from
the united states australia for somebody
to be looking after the south pacific
is very strong now tonga's parliamentary
speaker says it's important that any
future aid money benefits the people i
know this is a very sensitive topic but
you know tonga accepts a lot of foreign
aid from from many different places
around the world
and we just need to ensure that that aid
is funneled in a sustainable fashion at
the moment the aid is flowing in the
form of donations but longer term
rebuilding may be a more complicated
affair wayne hey al jazeera auckland